no existe un duelo que reúna más títulos
africanos como esté camerún egipto los
dos equipos son más ganadores de la
historia de la copa africana de naciones
con siete trofeos para los egipcios y
cinco para los cameruneses es la gran
semifinal que se va a disputar en el
estadio del mbe en yaundé que regresa a
la actividad después de aquella
estampida mortal antes del encuentro
entre camerún y comoras que dejó al
menos 8 muertos del lado de camerún
mucha confianza en un equipo que se ha
sostenido sobre todo en sus dos
delanteros en vincent aboubakar vícar
tocó de camby hombres desde con amplio
poder de fuego para los leones
indomables que no presentan bajas y que
tendrán obviamente el apoyo de su
público para buscar esta final en casa
del lado de egipto si cuenta con varias
bajas para este encuentro a la del
arquero de senagua se sumó la de su
segundo arquero de abajo quien salió
lesionado frente a marruecos una lesión
en el tendón deja afuera ahmed hegazi
pilar de la defensa y una suspensión
deja también descartado a marwan daúd
una de las alternativas que tiene el
portugués carlos queiróz en la defensa
aún así pidió
claro que no es un partido para tener
miedo ni se trata tampoco de una guerra
será un encuentro de fútbol un encuentro
que se espera sea muy cerrado muy
disputado y en el que prevalezca ya sea
el talento goleador de camerún o esa
fortaleza defensiva de egipto sostenida
también para la definición con un gran
mohamed salah que en los últimos
partidos ha mostrado su mejor nivel